verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
besucht die melker pioniere
zum einen wird oberstleutnant michael
fuchs integriert überreicht und damit
offiziell das kommando über das
pionierbataillon drei übergeben zum
anderen haben die melker pioniere eine
umfassende leistungsschau für die
verteidigungsministerin vorbereitet
tanna zeigt sie vom pionierbataillon
drei beeindruckt und wahrheit das
einzige bataillon dass sie insbesondere
auch am wasser wie wir hier sehen
seine expertise jeden tag oder
tagtäglich nicht mehr übungen sondern
leider auch in einsätzen im in- und im
ausland unter beweis stellen
niederösterreichs landtagspräsident
steht nicht an sich für den immer wieder
notwendigen einsatz des bundesheeres in
niederösterreich zu bedanken wir wissen
dass wir uns im katastrophenfall dem
bundesland niederösterreich auf diese
kräfte wirklich verlassen können vielen
dank dafür
bei der leistungsschau des
pionierbataillons 3 wird ein querschnitt
durch die vielfältigen aufgaben die an
dieser einheit gestellt werden gezeigt
wir konnten uns heute auch anschauen wie
brückenbau abläuft die sind auch ein
straßenbauer sie sind immer dann zur
stelle wenn niemand anderer mehr kann
das ist die aufgabe des österreichischen
bundesheeres also wirklich kompetenz zu
wasser und zu land muss man so ein
vielseitiges programm wurde dargeboten
die pioniere sind sichtbar
auch für die bevölkerung egal ob der
katastrophe anderen ereignissen die
kompetenz sichtbar brücke in zwei
stunden zu bauen ist keine technik auch
in finanziell schwierigen zeiten für das
österreichische bundesheer muss in
vieles investiert werden natürlich auch
in niederösterreich
verteidigungsministerin claudia tat
betont investiert wird in
niederösterreich in diesem wie eine
investitionssumme von 18,7 millionen
euro weil wie gesagt sicherheit kann es
nicht zum nulltarif geben